[inaudible].
No,
no.
[inaudible].
No.
Hello everyone and welcome to the lange
focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today I am going to talk about the
Spanish language.
As you may know,
Spain has more than one language,
so when I say Spanish,
I'm referring specifically to Castilian
Spanish,
which is spoken as a native language by
74% of the people of Spain and 99% of
the people of span including second
language speaker.
Castilian is the Spanish language that
grew to become one of the most important
global languages during this video.
I might refer to it as Castilian to
contrast it with other languages of
Spain,
but usually I'll refer to it as Spanish.
Out of all languages in the world,
Spanish has the second largest number of
native speakers with 470 million native
speakers as well as another 90 million
who speak it as a second language.
It is also one of the most widely
dispersed languages with 44 countries of
the world having at least 3 million
native speakers of Spanish or more.
It is one of the six official languages
of the UN as well as an official
language of the European Union.
It is also an official language of 21
countries.
If we include Puerto Rico,
which is a territory of the US.
It also used to be an official language
of the Philippines,
but it is not any more.
Spanish is also the third most widely
used language on the Internet.
According to one source that I
consulted,
the use of Spanish online has grown by
800% in the past few years.
Spanish is a member of the Barrow
Romance Subfamily of the Romance
Language family.
Other members of that sub family include
Portuguese galicians and some people say
Katelyn,
like all romance languages.
Spanish developed from Vulgar Latin,
the spoken Latin that was brought to the
area by the Roman Empire.
Vulgar Latin evolved into numerous
regional dialects which eventually
became distinct enough to be considered
different languages.
There are documents from the ninth
century that are written in an early
form of Castilian Spanish or we could
say a late form of vulgar Latin.
In any case,
documents like these show that the
vulgar Latin dialects were becoming
separate languages.
By that point,
Castilian Spanish is the language that
our role is in the north central region
of the Berrien Peninsula called Castiel
and it grew more and more distinct from
its neighbor language Leo needs.
It became firmly established as a
distinct language in the 13th century
when King I'll funds,
oh decided to standardize the written
language for official use based on the
dialect spoken in Toledo.
It process,
which continued for a few hundred years
until the 16th century in the 13
hundreds of the southern part of the
Iberian peninsula was under the control
of al and the loose a Muslim controlled
territory that had previously controlled
most of the peninsula that Econ Kista,
which means the reconquest resulted in
the retaking of the Muslim areas and of
the spread of Castilian Spanish to the
south.
There it was influenced by the most
Arabic dialects.
Those were romanced dialects spoken by
Muslims in Alanda loose that contained a
lot of loan words from Arabic castilian
Spanish absorbed a lot of those Arabic
loan words up to 4,000
words or 8% of the modern languages
vocabulary.
Some common Spanish words of Arabic
origin are Asda,
which means until that comes from the
Arabic word Hata with the same meaning
or law,
which means I hope comes from the Arabic
word low shalla or in Shell law,
which means if it's God's will,
a set day,
which means oil as in olive oil comes
from the Arabic word as it with the same
meaning.
There were also a lot of words in
Spanish that begin with Aal out,
which is the Arabic definite article.
For example,
alcohol from the Arabic word alcohol,
which of course means alcohol and
alcohol day,
which means mayor comes from the Arabic
word,
alcohol d,
which means judge in Arabic.
That's just a couple of examples,
but there are lots of words beginning
with AOL in Spanish.
The Christian reconquest of the South
successfully ended in 1492 and that very
same year,
Spain began sending explorers like
Christopher Columbus abroad to build the
Spanish empire,
the Spanish language spread along with
the Empire to the Americas,
to the Spanish east indies,
which includes present day Philippines
and to some parts of Africa.
One area it spread to us,
Mexico,
which today has the largest Spanish
speaking population of any country with
120 million speakers of Spanish.
The variety of Spanish spoken in Mexico
varies somewhat from the variety spoken
in Spain and that's true for the other
Spanish speaking countries as well.
The standard written language is
basically the same everywhere,
but the spoken language has some
differences,
especially in pronunciation and in
vocabulary and especially in common
daily vocabulary like clothing,
food and things like that.
In Latin America,
various native languages influenced the
different local varieties of Spanish.
What's the best variety of Spanish to
learn?
Well,
the varieties are often categorized into
European,
Spanish and Latin American Spanish.
From what I understand,
there isn't a lot of difference for
beginners.
No matter which variety you'll learn,
you will be able to adapt to other
varieties quite easily.
Personally,
I've met more Spanish speakers from
Mexico than from any other country.
So for me that's the natural choice.
But for you it depends on which variety
you are most likely to use and which one
you're most interested in.
Like romance languages in general,
Spanish shares a lot of vocabulary with
English,
not identical vocabulary,
but related vocabulary that you can
figure out and you can more easily
remember if you associate it with the
related English words.
Let's take a look at a couple of
sentences.
Cuanto Cuesta when via Nueva York.
Okay,
so the first word Quanto that sounds to
me like quantity.
So I think it means how much because
this is a question.
The next word,
Cuesta.
Well,
I think that probably means cost.
The next word I know that means,
ah,
the indefinite article,
the next word via.
Well that looks like voyage to me or
voyage in French.
So I think it means a voyage or a trip.
And then I know means to,
and Nueva York,
of course,
that means New York.
So I think means how much does a trip to
New York costs if we translate it
literally,
how much costs a trip to New York.
Another sentence [inaudible] to say no
to movies.
So let's look at it word by word L.
I know that means the definite article
on bread.
That's a word I know from movies and
stuff.
I think that means if men come to say,
well,
I'm not sure,
let's come back to that one in a second.
[inaudible]
is up and I would do movie.
That means automobile car.
So go back to come to say,
well maybe that means conduct.
Or in this case you don't conduct an
automobile,
you drive an automobile.
So this means the man drives an
automobile or demand drives a car.
So you can see that.
You can figure out what those words
mean.
If you look at each word and analyze
them.
It's not always that easy.
But that's an easy example.
So you know what I mean?
And also if we look at the syntax of
those sentences,
we can see that they're very similar to
English.
So the first sentence again,
Quanto Questa in via a on Nueva York.
Um,
so how much costs a trip to New York?
So quite similar to English,
but just sort of simplified the next
sentence.
The man drives a car.
That one is word by word,
exactly the same as English.
So it's translatable directly.
Of course the grammar gets more
complicated than that.
But just the most basic syntax is very
similar to English.
So this is one of the benefits of
learning a romance language for English
speakers.
According to the American Foreign
Service Institute,
Spanish is a category one language that
means that relatively speaking it is one
of the easier languages for native
English speakers to learn.
So what are you waiting for and then
some Spaniel or should I say
[inaudible]?
I'm not sure because Spanish speakers
themselves can't actually agree on this
issue.
In the red colored countries,
the preferred term is custody ended,
the blue colored countries,
the preferred term is espanol.
And in Spain you can see that there is
some disagreement about which term is
best.
If you're a native speaker of Spanish,
maybe you can tell us what you think
about that in the comments down below
and other people you can leave your
comments to.
Thank you for watching.
Have a nice day.